-The President tried
to paint his opponent
as drugged up and senile,
and it didn't work.
But he's still moving forward
with plan B,
lying about voter fraud
and trying to the steal
the election.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
Donald Trump want to create
the impression
that he is a permanent fixture
in our lives,
that there's nothing we can do
to get rid of him.
It's what he tried to do
in New York
by putting his name
on every building
in big gold letters
and on highway signs
and parking his dumb plane
at LaGuardia.
Even the pigeons are starting
to sound like him.
-Coo, coo.
This is a coo.
-Trump wants us to think
that he'll always be here
and there's no point in voting
against him
because we could never
get rid of him.
That's why he wouldn't shut up
at Tuesday's debate.
That's why he commandeers
the national spotlight
on a daily basis by saying
something insane
and forcing us all
to think about him.
Or why last night in another one
of his all-you-can-breath
Covid buffets,
he once again suggested
that he might stay in office
for another 16 years.
-What are they gonna do with
eight, 12, maybe 16 years?
I said, "Let's hang it up.
Let's hang it up."
16 more years.
-Crushed his time tables.
Didn't know he was gonna
be able to do that.
But another 16 years?
The last four have already
felt like 16.
16 more would feel like 64.
I asked our graphics time
to computer generate
an image of what
I would look like
after another 16 years of Trump,
and this what they came up with.
Oh, well, at least I still
have the show.
But despite what Trump says,
it is very much
within our power to get rid
of him and end all this.
That's what Tuesday's debate
was all about,
and that's why Trump
and his allies
have been lashing out
at everyone
including the moderator,
Fox News host
Chris Wallace,
after the negative reaction
to Trump's grotesque
performance.
At last night's rally,
Trump complained
that Wallace had the temerity
to interrupt him.
-I said, "Sleepy Joe, name one
law enforcement group
that supports you."
And then Chris Wallace says,
"Don't do that."
Can you believe this guy?
I was debating
two people last night.
You can riot. That's okay.
Arson's okay,
but challenging Sleepy Joe
is totally off limits.
Ah, so disappointed in Fox.
-The Commission
on Presidential Debates
is considering changes
for the next debate,
and I just like to say to them
best of luck.
You know the format's
not the problem, right?
It's not like it's hard
to follow the rules.
I mean, she did it.
What are you gonna do?
Cut his mic?
At this point if you took
his mic away,
he'd probably just grow
a new one Terminator-style.
[ Chuckles ]
That turned out a lot better
than I thought it would.
Did it again, Manny!
[ Laughter ]
There's only one way to get
Trump to behave at debates,
and if no else will say it,
I will.
Anytime he breaks the rules,
a hologram of Fred Trump
should appear and say,
"What part of wait your turn
don't you understand, Donald?"
"I'm sorry, Papa.
I'm just in so over my head,
and you're not here
to bail me out."
"And I'll tell you
something else,
you so called son of mine.
Picture perfect,
I paint a perfect picture.
Bomb the hoochies
with precision.
My intention's to get richer."
Is the hologram of Fred Trump
singing the lyrics
to "Ain't Nothin'
But A Gangsta Party?"
Oh [bleep]
Yeah, this is the same song
from the Coachella
Tupac holgram.
I guess we forgot to wipe it.
That is a real long walk.
[ Laughter ]
But I think we had fun.
Some times you got to enjoy
the view, everybody.
Also, any changes you make
Trump's just gonna
start whining.
He never stops whining.
Trump's allies are like him,
petulant children
who whine and moan unless
you let them rant
uninterrupted
for 90 minutes straight.
They're just bummed because
their genius strategy
of claiming Joe Biden
is senile backfired
when it turned Trump's
the one who's brain
is mostly room temperature
Velveeta.
Trump and his cheerleaders
on Fox spent weeks,
weeks insisting his opponent
was an doddering old man
with dementia who needed
drugs and a ear piece
to get through a debate.
And then the debated happened,
and it turned out
the only candidate
who sounded like he mixed
the dogs Valium with Jose Cuervo
is Trump.
And by the way, when you're
lagging with seniors
in swing states
due to a raging pandemic
you failed to contain, I'm not
sure calling your opponent
a brain-dead geezer
is the like awesome
campaign strategy
you think it is.
Once you're 77,
you're basically dead.
Anyway, the seniors love me.
In case you needed reminding,
Trump spent weeks
challenging Biden
to a drug test,
and then as proof for his
psychotic claims,
cited the Internet.
-Do you really belive
that Joe Biden
will be on any type of
performance enhancing drug
at the debates
or are you just joking?
-No, I'm not joking.
I mean, I'm willing
to take a drug taste.
I think he should, too.
People say he was on performance
enhancing drugs.
A lot of people have said that.
A lot of people
have written that.
Take a look.
Why don't you just check --
You can check out the Internet.
You'll see plenty
of people say it.
They gave him a big fat
shot in the ass,
and he comes out.
[ Laughter ]
And for two hours, he's better
than ever before.
-It sounds like Trump just saw
"Awakenings" on the plane
and thought
it was a documentary.
Also it's telling
that's how Trump
thinks you get a shot
of Adderall,
because it means that's how he
gets a shot of Adderall.
Just give me a
little booty bump, Doc.
Straight up the wazoo.
Also very telling when the
President cites a source
that wouldn't be accepted
on a high school term paper.
And if Biden's on performance
enhancing drugs,
like what's your
explanation then?
Are you on performance
decreasing drugs?
You know what drug
you should take?
You should take whatever drug
makes you smile normal.
I mean,
look at this neck strains.
It's the face you make
when you slam
a glass of OJ right
after you brush your teeth.
It looks like he tried
to poison James Bond drinks
but accidentally
mixed up the glasses.
Here you are, James.
I believe I had the martini,
shaken, not stirred,
and you had the diet coke
in a can.
Ooh! Oh, I switched them.
Oh, oh, oh, no.
I'm tightening up.
Can you get my Epipen, James?
Oh, don't be a dick, James.
Just do it, James.
I need it in the butt.
Just straight up the wazoo.
Oh, this you won't do, James?
After everything, this is the
line you won't cross?
Oh, the great James Bond.
So, Trump claims his opponent
[laughs]
was the one who is senile
and needed drugs
to get through the debate.
And then the debate happened
and Trump not only
couldn't keep his mouth shut,
but when it was his turn
to speak, he said stuff
like this.
Insulin, it's going to --
It was destroying families,
destroying people, the cost.
I'm getting it for so cheap
it's like water.
You know in Europe they lived
in forest cities.
They're forest cities.
The car has gotten so expensive
because they have
computers all over the place.
-He sounds like a first-time
film student
writing a sci-fi script
in a Starbucks.
Open on Moonbase Alpha,
nestled in a forest city,
Insulin flows like water.
The sky is
filled with flying cars,
which are expensive
because they have computers
all over the place.
Maybe Trump should stick
to interrupting.
When he actually
has to answer a question,
he sounds like the worst member
of your Taboo team.
Oh, it's a movie.
They live in forest cities.
Computers all over the place.
[ Buzzer ]
It was "Star Wars,"
but I wasn't --
It's not my fault.
I wasn't allowed to say
Star or Wars.
Even Trump's own campaign
acknowledge
privately that he went full
psycho with the debate.
-One person who's familiar
with his debate prep,
Anderson, said they prepared him
to be aggressive
but not to be Jason from
"Friday the 13th,"
and that is the perception
of how his performance was.
-Yeah, I mean, even Jason
didn't interrupt that much
unless you were a sexy teen
taking a shower.
Jason's whole thing
was that he was invulnerable
and had superhuman strength.
Trump always looks
like he just climbed a ladder
to get wherever he is.
Looks like he'd fall over with
one push like a Jenga tower.
Why would you want to be Jason
at a debate anyway?
The plot of "Friday the 13th"
wasn't a mystical killer
in a hockey mask shouting down
his rivals
while laying out a vision
for the future.
If anything,
Trump would be less scary
if he wore a Jason mask.
Ah!
Oh. Oh, thank God.
It was just Jason.
But it was important to see
one of Trump's
deranged conspiracy theories
disproven in real time
in front of a national
television audience
because he's counting on
conspiracy theories
to stay in power.
That's why he keeps
repeating his completely
unfounded lies about the dangers
of mail-in voting
as he did again at the debate.
-As far as the ballots
are concerned, it's a disaster.
If you have a unsolicited --
They're sending millions
of ballots
all over the country.
There's fraud,
they found them in creeks,
they found some
with the name Trump,
just happened to have
the name Trump
just the other day
in a waste paper basket.
They have mailmen
with lots of --
Do you see what's going on?
Take a look at West Virginia.
Mailmen selling the ballots.
They're being sold, they're
being dumped in rivers.
-They found them in creeks
and rivers?
Why is he talking like a
wild-eyed frontiersman.
There's ballads dumped
in the creeks and rivers.
This would shock you that's
completely made up.
There's no known incident
of ballots
being dumped in creeks
or rivers,
but I'm betting Trump said that
because he has definitely
dumped stuff in rivers.
When you're a New York
real estate grifter
with mob ties, the East River is
basically your filing cabinet.
We're not gonna see
Trump's tax returns
until they're accidentally
brought up in a fishing net.
I-I don't see anything
under value of golf course
quite like that before.
Well, just another day in the
life of a Maine fisherman.
That's not even the most
insane version
of Trump's mail ballot
fever dream.
Recently he told his supporters
to watch out
for ballots being
flushed down toilets.
-Get out there and vote,
and keep your eyes open
if you see any shenanigans,
which you probably will.
Okay, if you see people,
like dumping things,
flushing things.
-So, you want your supporters
to watch out for ballots
being flushed down the toilet?
First of all,
there's a good chance
Trump thinks
this is a voting booth.
-Ridiculous. I had to go all the
way to a construction site
to vote, and it was not
a pleasant experience.
Trump's bombarding us with these
lies for two reason.
One, to destroy confidence
in the election
and make us all think
it's hopeless,
and two, to set the stage
for a Supreme Court battle
that will hand him a victory
even if he loses.
He's repeatedly said as much,
including in Tuesday's debate.
-Are you counting
on the Supreme Court
including Justice Barrett,
to settle any disputes?
-Yeah. I think
I'm counting on them
to look at the ballots,
definitely.
We need nine justices.
You need that.
With the unsolicited millions
of ballots that they're sending,
it's a scam, it's a hoax.
Everybody knows that.
And the Democrats know it
better than anybody else,
so you're going to need nine
justices up there.
I think it's going
to be very important.
Paper ballots are very simple.
Whether they counterfeit them,
forge them,
do whatever you want.
-Counterfeit them, forge them,
flush them.
In fact, I've been going from
bathroom to bathroom
recovering ballots that were
flushed by Democrats.
Those were all votes for me.
Just can't read them now.
And Republicans
across the country
with the help
of Trump's campaign
are already setting the stage
for just such a legal battle
by suing to delay counting
or invalidate ballots
in swing states like Wisconsin,
Pennsylvania,
Michigan and Texas.
Trump's strategy is two-pronged,
to undermine the election
and to create the impression
that he's inevitable.
We cannot get rid of him,
but we can.
It's in our power to end this.
We can repudiate Trump
and the GOP
and give our democracy a...
-Big fat shot in the ass.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.